[Applause]
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help
people build wealth do work that they
love and create actual amazing
relationships thanks for joining us
America Merry Christmas to you we're so
glad you're with us Jade washaw Ramsey
personality newly minted brand new
author money's not a math problem
Breaking Free from broke is George
camel's new book and I'm glad for what I
have is Rachel Cruz's new book all in
the Ramsey store right now but Jade's
with us to help me answer the questions
this hour about your life your money
your work and your Christmas budget oh
wait we'll just put that in there 8825
5225 Kristen starts this hour in Tulsa
Oklahoma hi Kristen how are you I'm good
how are you doing better than we deserve
what's up in your world um well thank
you for taking my call um so my husband
of 16 years uh passed away two months
ago I'm so sorry yes thank Lord y'all
are young how old was he um I'm 39 uh we
have five children and he was 46
wow so what happened um well he had been
battling uh cancer for um three years
and then he had a really intensive
radiation treatment to his liver and
then he had some neck issues so it was
on lots of pharmaceuticals so with with
that and the disease and the treatment
his his body just gave out
so it happened very quick yeah thank you
I appreciate that so um
I never paid a bill in 16 years and so
I'm left to Steward our five children
and um all of our finances and um I want
a steward as well um but I'm feeling uh
zero confidence without him leading in
this area yeah he's been in he was in
charge of it for all of that time he yes
100% in charge how old are your babies
uh my oldest is 15 and my youngest is
four so was there insurance that came
about yes and not is actually my primary
question is so what he had a few life
insurance policies and I was going to
tell you what debts we had and to see if
it's better I remember him telling me a
long time ago to take the insurance
insurance money and pay off the
mortgages but I know we've refinanced
since then and obviously situations it's
just different now so I I wanted a
nonbiased opinion on what would be you
call the wrong place for that we're
extremely
bied we're we're biased to try to help
you so what what how much insurance was
there okay it was it's going to be about
720,000 how much debt do you have so we
have three mortgages um our primary
mortgage we the value is
496 and we the payoff is
267 now our rate is
2.65 so P off you said the value of the
house is 500 yes and you owe two two
what 67 okay do you have any other debt
other than that mortgage you said you
had three mortgages yes so we have two
rental properties that actually um we
net about $1,200 a month on what is the
value what's the uh equities in those
properties what give me the value of
rental property number one and the
mortgage on rental property number okay
it's 319 319 value and the mortgage on
that one is is 109 okay and the other
one is valued at what 231 okay and uh
the value is
what I'm Sor 2318 we we owe 88 on it 88
okay oh wow so you got a little bit of
equity not a ton uh in both of them but
you could pay off everything and still
have a substantial amount of money left
yeah yes okay now who was handling all
the tenants and the landlording he was
yes he was okay so we have two
complicated things here that you have to
learn uh in a crem course how how to
handle the the monthly personal finance
issues at home and learn how to be a
landlord yes
okay which I do have a lot of family
here I don't care um I mean it's nice
that they're there but they're not do it
for they're not gonna do it for well do
you want to be a
landlord um no not necessarily I the
good thing is I mean the rent you've
been a full-time Mom all this time yes
and I actually just got my master's last
year and I am actually a
counselor cool okay so you have the
ability to create some income I do okay
all right and so I do have I'm gonna
have social security um and I have a
better idea now what that's going to
look like um for me and the kids
okay Jay jump in anywhere you want here
but I'm pretending like at this moment
that you're my little sister M okay yes
I love that and if you were my little
sister what would I tell you to do I
personally love real estate I own a
bunch of it but it sounds to me like you
don't need landlording on top of five
kids and trying to learn how to handle
money for the first time in 16 years
that's what I would say so I'm probably
selling these two houses for one reason
and one reason only and that's to
simplify your life okay your life
doesn't need to be any more complicated
in the middle
of the pain and the new found stress of
having to handle some other stuff Plus
you said they cash flow 1,200 a month
combined yeah that's I you can go out
and make that and way more like I don't
think it's do you see what I'm saying so
if you were to sell those take the money
from those and pay off your home you'd
have $700,000 to
invest and sit down with a smartvestor
pro with some mutual funds create an
investment account you've got a pile of
money coming in for social security for
the five kids you can use that money the
money you earn as a counselor and a
little bit of money off the 700 and
easily mathematically by by the math
would be easy not the life but the math
would be you could easily take care of
your family yes yes and that's really
what I want I don't want you dealing
with some tenant okay yeah um I do have
on my car I owe 20,000 pay it off pay it
off today what else do you have is that
it that's it that's it it was a
threeyear just and never borrow never
borrow money again okay that's rule
number one cuz you have a paid for house
a paid for car five kids and a big old
pile of money and you're going to live
on less than you make so that this is
sustainable into
perpetuation okay and then you've taken
care of yourself now here's what we're
going to do okay uh you you mentioned
Steward which is typically a word by
used by people of Faith so you're a
person of faith I assume 100% okay so
are we and my book yes that my heavenly
father gave me told me to take take care
of widows M so you're going to be taken
care of we're going to put you into
Financial Peace University into every
dollar and I'm going to assign one of
our Ramsey coaches to you to get you up
and get you trained and help you get
sustainable with your knowledge and it's
all on us thank you so much thank you so
much Merry Christmas honey Merry
Christmas I'm so sorry you're going
through this but we're going to walk
with you okay thank you so much you hold
on the team will pick up and get you
taken care of this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey if you're in over your head with
student loans and tired of getting calls
from collection agencies if private
student loan debt is taking away your
financial peace and you don't see any
way out you need y refi they're not a a
debt settlement company and they're not
connected to a bank why refi refinances
defaulted private student loans that
other places won't touch and gives you a
custom loan built for you based on your
ability to pay so when you refinance
your private student loan debt with Y
refi you'll have a payment you can
afford with a low fixed interest rate
you couldn't get anywhere else to help
you stick to your budget and work the
debt snowball and you can save thousands
of dollars to learn more about this
custom refinancing option and a lumpsum
payoff option you could qualify for
after 24 months call
8442 Ramsey or go to Y rei.com
[Music]
Ramsey
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America open phones at
88255 225 those of you that are
considering getting on the every dollar
app this time of year and getting into
Financial Peace
University the last call we took from
the uh lady with five children who
hadn't touched a bill in 16 years tells
you that you need to go through that
class because uh well I don't mind and
I'm honored for us to be helping her um
I don't want you to be in her situation
you should never be in a situation where
one spouse does everything and the other
spouse has no idea what's going on M
yeah that's when you said set yourself
up like that you never know what's going
to happen in life and of course you hope
the worst doesn't happen but you've got
to know what's going on with your
finances even if something catastrophic
doesn't happen it's your money it you
can't even argue intelligently if you
don't know what's going
on that's true you lose every argument
oh my goodness that's a good point you
can't I mean you you cuz you end up
being the little boy that's being taken
care of by his mommy or the little
princess who the husband or whatever I
mean those are exem dysfunctions right
but uh hers was hers wasn't that he just
she had a bunch of kids and he's taking
care of the bills that's okay that that
that and I do the majority of the
finances no kidding at our house but I
can 100% assure you that Sharon knows
two things about every item of ours and
ours is
complicated um you know with businesses
and real estate holdings and other stuff
that we have uh she knows two things
number one she knows exactly what where
everything is and where we stand on all
of our money okay no question about any
of that and she knows where the bills
are and how we get how they get paid and
number two she knows who to go toh for
the various information for insurance
information for investment information
for business information you know and so
on so and that's all planned out and
laid out and so um and she actually got
me on something the other day that I
hadn't done she said you need to go in
and the wills got everything in detail
all everything's laid out in detail but
I don't know what you want done with
your collections of things ah hey that's
the first time you've talked about
Sharon and not said it in her
voice okay
Dave Dave what what am I going to do
with all those dad gum guns there you go
I don't know what to do with 300
guns like do I think I think I need to
make a list and tell you what to you
know who I sell them or which kid needs
to get which and yeah that's right and
so that's important even something as
simple as um passwords oh and knowing
how to get no I've got that that I got
them all in one one of I've got one of
the apps I don't endorse it so I'm not
going to say what it is but everything's
in that and my personal assistant and my
son who's president of the company and
my wife all have access to that and it's
a it's a treasure Trove of passwords get
get you in everything so uh it's all
store including safe M safe codes to get
in the saf in various houses and stuff
so all that but you gotta guys you
cannot you you leave yourself at a
disadvantage you the husband felt like
he was serving his wife but she didn't
have to fool with that but he leaves her
set up to now she feels completely
lacking in confidence but to your point
talking about every dollar the great
thing about it is makes both of you do
it together you're both on it it's on
both of your phone right you know
they've got the mobile version and of
course the the desktop version but if
you have the mobile over it's on your
phone there's no you know you open up
the app and yeah you can it's the same
login right so there's no reason for you
to not even if you're not the one that
actually sends out the payments or even
if you're not the one who actually types
in the amounts right because there
usually is one person who kind of takes
the lead on that there's no reason that
you can't spend 3 minutes a day right
you you first get up get get up in the
morning look at look at the app look at
the budget and see what's on there
that's just part of adulting hasht
adulting there you go yeah it just it it
is it's just um you make better
decisions the preacher when you went
down the aisle
D and now you are one one so when you
make a decision without the other half
of your brain mhm because now you're one
and so if you're doing this by yourself
you're just a half that's a really good
point you're using half of your brain
yeah so you you are now redesigned to
use your entire brain so Sharon and I
make
large giving decisions large financial
decisions uh large time block decisions
if we're going to do you know what we
going with our time we manage our
calendar our budget our uh future
planning together and it keeps a it's a
really good marriage tool because it
keeps us in high levels of
communication and so I just want to
encourage all of you both of you need to
know what's going on that's just healthy
now again one of you is always going to
be you know maybe your wife is a CPA and
loves doing numbers she's going to take
the primary lead right and that's cool
there's nothing wrong with that but you
don't need to be completely freaking
clueless MH it just sets you up for
problems I know that's right Rob is in
Cincinnati hey Rob welcome to the Ramsey
Show Hi how are you better than I
deserve what's
up yeah so my fiance and I are getting
married next
October for a house thank you thank you
I have
$997,000 in a traditional brokerage
account two grand in a separate checking
account to help pay the remaining Seven
Grand for our part of the wedding which
includes rings and whatnot right now our
household income is around 120 Grand you
don't have a household
fi it will be when you're in October
it'll be a household right now you have
you and her what do you what do you
make we make
$120,000 Hy there ain't no we yet it's
we in October now it's me what do you
make I make about make about $60,000 and
so does she okay great okay thank you
yeah thank you okay so when you are
married it'll be1 120 right now each of
you make 60 that's awesome very cool how
old are you
guys I'm 28 and my fiance is 26 and
you're gonna go buy a house after you
get
married well that's the thing we want to
stve for a little bit we don't know I've
lived in apartments my whole life um I
just I don't know where to begin we only
have one type of debt and it's her car
which is about $14,000 remaining does
she does she have any
money I do not well yes she does she has
a savings account that her dad started
for her it's not a rth IRA it is around
21 to $23,000 last time we talked which
was a couple weeks ago so she could take
money she should pay off her
car yes and that was going to be part of
my question too if we just pay that off
immediately with that she should if you
suggest her to pay it off will she pay
it
off I think so I don't know how her dad
would feel about it but she's an adult
it's her decision I think she should
yeah but that's interesting that you
said that I like that okay all right so
you got to finish up the wedding and
then you're going to get married and
then you're thinking about buying a home
when ideally maybe 2026 oh wow for a
couple years okay so you're put you're
going to pile up cash like crazy and and
then go buy a nice property with a good
down payment or pay cash
huh that's the goal I just don't know
how to go about that with saving up for
a down payment if I should just keep
that money separate like in a checking
account or no you got it in a brokerage
account that's fine put it in some
mutual funds or uh something like an S&P
500 or you can put it in a money market
high yield savings is fine because
you're only going to do for a couple
years you don't want to take a lot of
risk with it um and you do need to keep
it separate you want to make sure you've
got 3 to six months saved first keep
that somewhere else and then when you
start saving up for that down payment
keep that like where Dave said I love
the idea of saving like crazy for two
years and just pilot it in that that
high yield savings account or whatever
it is it's just the house account we'll
call it right you just dump money in
there dump money in there dump money in
there let me tell you there's two things
that are very good about that Rob uh
thing number one is being married eight
a year 18 months before you make a
decision on which house to buy is very
wise because after you been living in
the same house married people for a year
you will make a different Home Choice
than you will today
facts right we always laugh and say it
takes uh in this case may be more not
maybe more true than not based on the
father comment but it takes it takes
about a year of being married to know
how close to your mother-in-law to buy
not too close that's the thing right so
you got to get to know each other you
got to get to know life and so then
during that time the second wise thing
is you're going to pile up a big old
pile of cash mhm and you're either going
to pay cash or almost pay cash for this
house I love what you're doing me too go
do that do not do any of this together
until both of you have the same name
this is the Ramsey
[Applause]
[Music]
Show
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100%
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see why blinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to get
up to 40% off that's blinds.com rules
and restrictions May
[Music]
apply Merry Christmas America Jade
washaw Ramsey personality is my co-host
today in the lobby of ramsy Solutions on
the Dead free stage Tom and tenica are
with us hey guys how are you good doing
great merry Christmas good to have you
Merry Christmas where do you all live we
live in Kansas City actually Ates in
Kansas but it's about an hour from
Kansas City yeah know it yeah wow
welcome to Nashville how much have you
guys paid off
$1,944 27 I love it how long did this
take 48 months good for you and your
range of income during that four years
it was uh
160,000 all of that
time uh well it at the end it was about
170,000 good what do you guys do for a
living I work in health it and I work in
law enforcement ah very good what are
you doing in law enforcement I'm a
contractor for Homeland sec
oh wow well good to have you guys
welcome to Nashville hey I love it yes
so what kind of debt was this
$255,000 we had well I had student loans
of about 42
43,000 and we also had some
consolidation loans we had credit cards
lots of credit cards we had I think it
was like 21 credit cards that we having
gracious yes and just uh just getting
rid of those get makes your hip work
better
yeah that's for sure but we also had a
loan out against our 401K prior to FPU
wow okay so we were paying that off as
well so just lots of personal loans and
just student loans and St what happened
four years ago that got you guys on this
Ramsay process cuz I mean you went from
One Direction all the way to the other
direction this is a completely
turnaround yes we uh were doing pre uh
marital counseling mhm and we put our
finances together obviously and my wife
looked at me and said uh we're not
getting married it's not happening whoa
I did so I looked at her pre-marriage
counseling fail yes yes so uh the Holy
Spirit came upon me and I looked at my
wife and said it's going to be all
right and at the time I didn't have
anything to back that up with MH uh but
uh later on we were in church and up on
the screen came
FPU we looked at each other and said
that's us mhm and here we are so how
long have you been married we got
married July 27th 2019 okay and within a
couple of weeks we were sitting in
church never heard of FPU and it came
across the screen shout out to City
Center Church Pastor and Matt um Matt
and Jeanie perky at our church
yes for offering your program we were
there and saw it come across the screen
and as soon as we saw it we literally
just looked at each other and we knew
that that was us the Lord had confirmed
what he had said before that so we both
knew we were on the same page and knew
and also you were like I was
right
exactly Financial Peace University so
you guys jump in there and boy are
you're ready we are ready jumped in with
Gaz was it wasn't like you had to be
talked into anything you're like
something's got to change and this is it
y it follow the baby steps they work
there you go and treat treat your budget
like it's a the Bible like it's a
lifelong commitment okay stick to it in
other words STI to it yeah absolutely I
like that part and we knew God was
behind it so that gives you a drive
confidence yes 100% now you guys had it
it lowers the whining it does it does if
God said do something it's like okay I
really can't wh I can whine about it but
it's kind of particularly lame yeah
that's a good point but what a journey
through it to watch How I mean there
were so many times that we just looked
at our bank account we were like where
did this money come from how are we
paying off all of this and how is it it
literally did just snowball you know
like you like you say Dave it's just it
works well I wanted to ask you guys
because you guys have a nice income and
you've had it it sounds like the
majority of the time um so what was the
hardest part I mean did you guys have to
side hustle or was it truly just looking
at the budget and just cutting back we
really did and I have to give kudos to
my husband um he worked overtime for
over well over two years I mean he just
we both went in with gazelle like
intensity and he was working 12-hour
days I mean he was working 60 plus hours
every week consistently and on top of
that we have he had an hour or more
drive just to get to work every day so
literally he was going driving working
coming home falling bed getting up and
doing the same thing in a couple of
hours wow and thank you for that but he
did that was our our number one thing we
also we have about an acre a little over
an acre of land and so we got some
cattle and so we sold beef just off of
that little you know what we could do so
no major ticket items we just kind of
like put everything together we did
Poshmark and just got rid of things that
we didn't need and on eBay and he did
Facebook Marketplace I don't get on
Facebook but he does
Facebook Marketplace and just being
intentional yes just being intentional
and constantly to keep that going so and
God did the rest obviously paying
attention working on it together were
the keys what are the big things that
you took away from Financial Peace
University that you went I should I knew
that or are that's brand new information
I never heard that
before you have anything
uh just that
just follow your steps I think that the
one big thing that I got from it is that
with man it's impossible but With God
all things are
possible and I thank you for hearing
God's voice with starting this and to
know that you can't do it on your own
you know but if you trust God and you
are obedient and you follow the steps
that it really does work and it makes
sense it makes sense yeah I mean the the
principles are are grandma common sense
but they're also biblical obviously get
out of Deb stay on a budget live on less
than you make be generous absolutely
right um be saving and investing every
one of those things show up in scripture
and they show up in Grandma's Common
Sense Absolut and uh but most most of us
are forgot in both things in America and
so when you come to them it's like brand
new information almost common sense is
not common you know and it just it wakes
you up and it energizes the crud out of
you you guys are amazing I'm so proud of
you thank you and I'd have to say Dave
when I was growing up and everything I
credit cards uh around my family and
stuff it's like if you didn't have a
credit card you weren't normal right
well that's
America and I was yeah and I grew up
very resourceful so I was already eating
beans and rice
like we had she country and I'm City
yeah love it well done you two thank you
well done okay so somebody's listening
they're brand new they're thinking about
getting married in pre-marriage
counseling they look up and they got
$200,000 in debt what do you tell them W
I tell them to trust God if if we can do
it if God can do it through us God can
do it through you there is nothing
that's impossible with him and follow
the baby steps like like Tom said they
do work wow don't give up stay diligent
God's got it I love it well played you
two well played Heroes wow love people
taking control of their lives and
stepping up and man you start your
marriage off on a great foot and uh
marriage counsel or pre-marriage
counseling went a little rough but the
marriage started off great yeah this is
great way to go guys hey we got the live
and give box for you it's got the baby
steps millionaires book in it uh because
that's where you're headed next uh Total
Money Makeover book you can give that
away and get somebody started and a
financial pece University membership
same thing you can go this is what did
it for us this changed everything for us
when our pastor and church start
teaching this by the way you pastors and
churches out there listen to that it's
important you have this class in there
cuz there's someone sitting there going
uh I need some help and it's like your
job to help them by having this class
available thank you guys 10,000
Financial Peace University classes last
year were taught wow 10,000 so uh it's
important it's very important thank you
guys Tom and tenica Kansas City area a
little about an hour West at Edison
count it down 215,000 paid off in 48
months making 160 to 170 let's hear a
great debt-free Scream 3 2 1
we de
free
yeah ah this is how it's done ladies and
gentlemen man Jade that's fun very good
very good this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
hey guys I've told you before about
Christian healthc Care Ministries a
health cost sharing Ministry but listen
to Jenna a chm member she says one of my
biggest concern conerns about
entrepreneurship and motherhood was
figuring out how to take care of our
health expenses but we have found a
solution that works for us in an
incredible way she loves that with chm
she can help other families who need it
and receive help back when her own
family has an eligible medical event chm
has been a godsend for Jenna that's her
chm story and it could be yours learn
more and join at chministries.org
budget
[Music]
$
5,000 yeah we're going to be giving away
$5,000 this week uh Wednesday December
the 20th is the last day to register for
the free Ramsey cash giveaway go to the
website Ramsey solutions.com giveaway
and sign up you can sign up every day
somebody's going to win it no purchase
necessary
$5,000 you ought to check it out M and
do it today because tomorrow is the last
day that is that's tomorrow yeah that's
right well depending on when you're
listening Wednesday the 20th that's what
your cut off time is and so don't miss
this John's in Orlando hey John welcome
to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's
up I am calling um I have um 10 rental
properties and I am considering selling
two of those to pay down two of them or
put that money towards my house so I'm
just trying to get your advice on that
okay how did you uh come to this
conclusion I don't know um I've been
buying over the past like three years
with the interest rates high right now
I've just been trying to kind of hold
off on purchasing and then just using uh
the equity that I do have to you know
move that around and and use it to make
the most sense for me I guess so do all
of the rentals have mortgages on them
all 10 of them um not all of them uh one
of them is paid off and then the other
nine do wow and the two that you're
talking about selling have some Equity
but they have
mortgages yes so um if you s those can
you pay off your
house no I can't um so between those two
I have about 210,000 worth of equity um
so I could use that to pay off two of
the rental properties that are worth
around 100,000 right now or that have
about 100,000 on the mortgages um do you
ow your home put that towards my house
um I owe about
555 listen if I'm honest with you my
goal Numero Uno would be to sell
whatever I have to sell to get my
personal Mortgage Debt free cuz it's
crazy to me to have all of this real
estate and juggling all these balls in
the air but your own personal mortgage
is not paid
off right yeah I and the only reason I
wasn't you know considering selling them
all or you know putting everything
towards um paying down my my mortgage is
just because I can comfortably cover it
you know just with my job so that you
know the goal the end goal is to have a
real estate portfolio and do that
full-time that's some stage so okay well
I mean John you can certainly go any
direction you want to go I love real
estate I've got a large real estate
portfolio myself uh several hundred
million dollars worth and um I pay cash
for everything I buy including real
estate or I don't buy it um because two
two things that happen when I do that
par three things happen when I do that
in real estate number one it's the best
way to get great bargains is close it
Friday and I'm paying cash and I want a
deal okay and so you can buy distressed
situations you can buy into bank oros
all everything else right uh and you can
do it quick and the quick means a lot to
people if you're looking for a bargain
number one number two when I pay cash um
my cash flow since I don't have any
payments is astronomically
amazing number three my risk my risk
profile goes way
down because you you just said some
really dangerous words like nothing like
no one ever lost a job in your industry
right well we know that's not
true yeah yeah I was um I was
considering you know taking that extra
amount of rent that i' would be getting
in you know from those two properties
that would be paid off yeah and throwing
that towards the mortgage you what do
you make a year the payment going be the
same uh about 250,000 good you got a
great income so here's what I would
challenge you to do you're you're
sticking your toe in the edge of doing
things the way I do it I'm way over here
on the right most real estate people are
leveraged all the way over on the left
correct you're kind of in the middle and
you're thinking about moving in my
direction but at a slower Pace maybe
than Jade was trying to get you to go
you follow me yes sir okay so let I
would challenge you to consider
establishing a strategy to become 100%
debt free before before you add to the
portfolio now we can do that two ways
three there are three variables one is
selling some property two is utilizing
your fabulous income to reduce debt and
three is time how much time is going to
elapse while we do this because five
years of making 250,000 is different
than two years making 250,000 okay so if
you take so if you said all right I'm
going to sell to I'm going to use that
rent that's freed up I'm going to crank
on my personal lifestyle and start
throwing it at something in this mix and
every time one of those is debt free
we're going to add to the cash flow to
get another one debt free and the cash
flow to get another one debt free to
where at the end of the story and the
story is a threeyear story a fiveyear
story we haven't added anything to the
portfolio we have subtracted two
properties or maybe more and have become
100% debt-free rentals and home dude do
you know how much money you're going to
have coming in then and how quickly
you'll be able to buy that next property
for cash it'll be amazing that's kind
what I was thinking too but you've got
you've got to dip back you got to dip
back to bottom and clear the clear the
table first before you see that
increased cash flow substantial
increased cash flow but so I I mean if
you want to go at it my point is if you
want to go at this a little bit more
gradual than Jade was suggesting I'm not
going to yell at you about that but I do
want you to lay a strategy out and
you're you're a uh uh uh you like
running the math and running the
spreadsheets don't you yes okay so run a
scenario out where you're done in five
years and then ask yourself okay what
would I have to change to what variables
do I have to change what else have I got
to sell in other words or what extra
lifestyle I got to cut to do it in three
years and when you do that you're going
to look at it and go I you're just going
to make you think about
it all right because it lowers the risk
profile and it raises the cash flow
every time you do this does that make
sense to you yeah it does yeah that's a
great plan very cool thank you for
calling in very interesting I wondered
if he had any other
debt I didn't I'm sorry I didn't give
you a chance to jump in here's well
here's what I was thinking this is what
Jade's brain
said the average person gets out of debt
two two and a half years I'd want a plan
that gets him out in two two and a half
years and then it CH go ahead you're the
real estate guy he's just the guy is a
process
I could see that I think he's going to
when he lays it out for 5 years the math
is going to talk to him he's going to
dial it back and do it in three I really
cuz that's how my brain works that's how
I kind of think I'm kind of I I kind of
get that guy I mean you you were that
guy I was that guy on the other no I
really wasn't he's much more
conservative than I was I borrowed on
everything I borrowed on the dog and the
cat it was chasing I mean I borrowed on
everything so uh he he's he's much more
chill and he's he you know he's got he's
got some equity and that kind of stuff
wait so that's that's chill cuz I'm
looking at this my heart's beaten fast
I'm thinking nine out of 10 properties
no I was I was like one of those idiots
on Tik Tok that's what I was like oh my
go that's that's why I'm willing to call
them idiots cuz I was one of them the
nothing down goobers oh yeah you know
yeah yeah I would go and borrow 100% of
the value of the house oh I did here's
worse than this okay I would buy a house
for 150,000 that was worth 250 mhm and
I'd borrow 250 on the 15 purchase put a
100 in my pocketo to go do the next deal
with oh yeah I'm clutching my pearls yes
all right all yeah your throat's
tightening up now yeah but that's how
dumb I was and I didn't think anything
about it to me it was just a Monopoly
game yeah well that's what everybody and
that's what these idiots on Tik Tok
they're doing the same St stupid stuff
but I mean uh the only thing tick
tocking when I was doing it was a clock
you know that was it you know but I mean
there wasn't anything like that it was
Tick Tock right all right I mean it was
just not there was it was there was no
cable TV even to tell you how to do it
it was just like you know oh boy nothing
down guys selling cassette tapes it's
like you go to the the ballroom of Hotel
the ballroom the tired ballroom at the
hotel and the guy with a polyester suit
and the Disco chain Starter Set gets up
there and he he's he's going to tell you
how to get rich and I was such a redneck
I believ the idiot oh my gosh and I
signed up for all of it man I did every
bit of it wow and that's why I get so
you know exercised about people putting
out that same stupid butt information 35
years later and acting like they
discovered something like this is new no
one doesn't know this you Boomers don't
know this information honey we invented
stupid before you were a gleam in your
mother's eye wow this is unbelievable
this is the ramsy show
[Music]
n
live from the headquarters of ramsy
solutions it's the ramsy show where we
help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships Jade washaw Ramsey
personality and author of the brand new
book money's not a math problem is my
co-host today as we answer your
questions about your life and your money
Merry Christmas we're so glad you guys
are with us thanks for hanging out
Christy starts this hour in Louisville
Kentucky hi christe welcome to the
Ramsey
Show hello Hi how are you doing great
thank you all for taking my I really
appreciate it sure what's
up okay well I used to be a single mom
of three divorce and my plan was after
got the kids out of the house cuz my
budget was really tiny to start tackling
my student loan debt and purchase my
house that I live in for my parents for
what they put in it to to get it going
for me and um two years ago I and kids
are out of the house now so two years
ago I've
remarried and I knew my husband had some
credit card debt from his prior
marriage however um and I know things
have been tight since we've been married
it's like we're Robin Peter to pay Paul
robing Paul to pay Mary and after
listening to y'all for the last couple
weeks I'm here like I can do this um do
the budgeting app the every dollar the
free version mhm I can we can do this
however we sat down he's got 22 credit
cards hey
yay well how much does it that's an crap
moment got his car oh I'm sorry that's
an old crap
moment yeah so this is where a lot of
our M's going to yeah think you know
yeah yeah how much does that how much
does he owe on these 20 2 credit
cards
18,000 and I guess he knew
this I'm assuming he did I hope he did
what was his reaction to your
reaction um he's like well um maybe you
know after the holidays take a debt
consolidation loan and yeah you can
always borrow your way out of
debt right that's dumb okay what was his
reaction is he ashamed of this does he
think he stupid did he feel
defensive um he was kind of defensive on
it a little bit because a lot lot of it
he said come from his prior
marriage so he's not is he currently
using credit cards or is is all
old um he he it this past weekend he
still using them yeah okay put a battery
in his car so you guys have some
conversations to have so what is your
income and what is his
income okay mine is 33,000 a
year he's doing door Dash so it's
anywhere why he not working six days
five to six days a week um why do he not
got a job that's a good question he
likes working on his own he says did he
have a job when you met him or he was
doing this when you met him
um whenever I met him he was doing lifon
Uber Nashville okay and making 1,200 a
week on that gross before taxes gasoline
and wear and tear on the car exactly he
might be breaking even
mhm okay so there's some problems here
how much student loans do you have by
the
way
110,000 okay yeah so so sometimes when
it sometimes when we get into debt it's
as easy as saying all right I make my
budget and I cut back here in there and
I you know over time I'm out of it and
then sometimes there's more to the
equation where there's an income side of
it where you can side hustle till you're
blue in the face and you're going to be
working it forever and in that case
that's kind of where you guys are this
core your core income is not where it
should be and the challenge here is for
both of you guys to really begin looking
at what's it going take for me to get my
income higher I mean 33,000 is the
average is 67,000 so you see where
you're at on that on that Spectrum what
do you do for
Li um customer service for who got
$110,000 worth of student
loans that's me and getting a degree in
what psychology and counseling because
that was the quickest thing I could get
I've always wanted to
teach and why are you not utilizing that
in some
way
um I really don't know if any job in our
in our little local area for that degree
without getting a masters yeah
okay it is probably limited because if
you're going to do counseling in Most
states you do have to have a master's
okay yeah but there's not there there's
a lot of things you can use psychology
for uh for instance you can move into
the marketing area of a company and make
three times what you're making so uh
Jade's right um how old are you two your
kids are grown you're 40 or
50 yeah I'm 46 he's fixing a turn 50
okay all right so this is the time that
you all have the
first most lucrative careers of your
lives and the both of you have to decide
what that is and start working on it you
don't want to be an 80y old Uber driver
mhm this is not a plan you don't want to
be doing door dash at
76 this is not a
plan you don't want to be in customer
service at
76 especially when you're looking at
110,000 student loans and 18,000 in
credit cards and everything you do like
put a battery in your car looks like
more credit card
debt something's got to change would you
agree oh yes yeah so I I'm with Jade I
think you guys do need to get on the
same page and I think you need to make a
commitment to borrow no more and to
begin to reduce these debts and you're
going to have to rethink both of your
careers because you're going to
struggle this is going to be very hard
20 years in front of you MH very
difficult if you guys do not deal with
this core issue you can try to ignore it
but it's going it's the elephant in the
room it's going to stomp around and
leave the furniture broken yeah you
making is this making sense to you yeah
you've avoided this and kicked the can
down the long down the road as long as
you can and now the can has come home
and hit you in the back of the head like
a boomerang
mhm 110,000 on student loan debt how
long ago were you in
school um graduated 200 and nine no 13
15 years was my guess I wasn't far off
okay yeah see it's time to deal with
this do you agree oh yeah kids are grown
and gone okay so we're going to get out
the credit cards we're going to have a
plastic surgery party tonight honey
we're chopping them all up every
stinking one of them this has to
end that's how I would have reacted had
we found this okay it wouldn't have been
as nice as you you're a little sweeter
than me this is stupid it has to stop
how about that one let's try that like
it there we go this is the Ramsey
[Music]
Show hey folks you know that sinking
feeling when you make an offer on a
house you love and then you hear there's
another offer you need the Churchill
Mortgage home buyer Edge super fast
pre-approval and a secured interest rate
plus a $5,000 seller guarantee gives
your offer the best chance of being
accepted the home buyer Edge from Church
Hill gives you an advantage over those
other guys go to Churchill mortgage.com
today to learn
[Music]
more
[Applause]
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality author of
money's not a math problem our latest
quick read release 57 Pages you can blow
through it one setting and you will
learn a lot from Miss Jade check it out
at the ramseys solutions.com store right
now the Ramsey Show question of the day
sponsored by neighborly your hub for
Home Services there are some things
around the house you can handle yourself
but electrical problems probably aren't
on the
list contact Mr Electric for licensed
professionals that's what you want there
you don't want this you want the
licensed professional it's a good idea
yeah they'll give you upfront pricing
and they'll take care of you from your
neighborhood Mr Electric online at
ne.com Ramsey today's question comes
from Arlo in Texas are those companies
that say they will help you deal with
the IRS legit my husband and I had
several years of unfiled taxes and fear
that we owe the IRS a huge amount of
money can those companies who claim that
they can stop the IRS from garnishing
your wages actually do it well I'm just
wondering why you're waiting till you
get to the point of garnishing of wages
why not just dig a Little Deeper contact
the IRS and find out what you owe and
pay it and by the way if you're in baby
step 2 if you're working on paying off
your debt this is going to go right to
the top of the list this is going to be
Numero Uno nothing nothing ahead of it
because you don't want I would change
one thing in that suggestion we're not
going to contact the IRS uh we're going
to contact a tax professional and file
our taxes well yeah you got to file your
taxes tell the IRS what you owe they're
not going to tell you what you you don't
want to ask the IRS anything cuz they
don't know either they're dumber than IR
rock that is true they send stat they
just make up crap so but no you need to
catch up on your tax filings and figure
out where you are and the answer to your
question is no those companies don't
work yeah okay so here's the
thing if you file your
taxes and get caught up the likelihood
of you being criminally charged for
failure to file is very
low when you come forward come out of
the cold so to speak get back on the GD
so to speak and file your taxes they
very seldom criminally charge you they
because failure to pay the IRS is not a
criminal offense failure to file is a
criminal offense so about
2572 people or something like that every
year last year it
27572 get put in jail for not filing
their taxes it is a criminal offense m
okay so you don't want to screw around
with this you need to right now before
Christmas immediately get online at
ramsy solutions.com click on our tax
professionals our elps our endorsed
local providers for taxes get your crap
together go over there and get your
taxes filed immediately even if you
don't pay them a dime and you don't have
a dime that's right that's step one get
rid of the probability of a criminal
issue then we'll deal with the mathema
IAL issue of can they garnish e wages
and are there reductions okay so let's
get into that for just a second because
people are spending more time at home
during the holidays and watching cable
TV and cable news where you see we have
former IRS agents working for us and we
can reduce your tax burden if you have
$10,000 or more in IRS debt contact us
and we'll make your life
okay in the fine print it says bull crap
okay so uh cuz that's what it is so
here's the
deal that you can have a tax
professional represent you that is not
on cable TV and they can help you with
the process there's a couple of things
you can do thing one is what Jade said
scratch the money together and pay them
if you're not anywhere near that at
least contact them and you can get on a
payment plan yeah it's ridiculous
penalties and ridiculous interest you
don't want to do that if you can get the
money anywhere else including borrowing
it somewhere else and changing your IRS
debt into credit card debt I would have
you do that CU it's a better deal hey
say that again because I told somebody
that one time and they had my head for
it no I you I you've got one kind of
debt that's bad debth I would rather you
have a different kind of debt that is
better debt I agree okay let me just
tell you credit card debt is
bankruptable credit card debt has to go
through a legal process to garnish of
your wages IRS debt is not bankruptable
IRS debt has a higher interest rate than
credit card debt has IRS debt can W can
garnish your wages without going to
court they don't have to get a judge's
permission all other forms of debt have
to do have to so this is the worst kind
of debt to have so if you can make it
into another kind of debt you got a
$20,000 IRS debt I would lot rather you
owe $20,000 on a credit card then
$20,000 to the KGB amen amen okay and if
you guys don't like Jade saying that
well you're stupid okay so Jade was
right when she said that that's just
don't be stupid okay it's it makes makes
life painful so the uh the the so now
the next thing is this you you do the
payment plan now the other thing they
say is we can reduce your tax
burden
bull yeah they'd have to do something
Shady no there there's one way you can
do it legally but it's so thin and
narrow is the door it's called an OIC an
offer and
compromise and you can submit to the IRS
your situation and ask that they accept
less than the actual tax debt try to get
them to settle with you like as a
hardship yep when do they approve an
offer in compromise to take your
$100,000 debt and allow you to pay 20
instead okay well you'd have to prove
that you have nothing yeah no income no
potential for income no assets no house
no car no money you are what you have to
prove what they call pper status wow
poor people you got to be homeless
basically penniless and then they will
approve a compromise because they don't
think they're going to get their taxes
anyway but I'm telling you to get an OIC
through and I've gotten a few of them
through I've worked with clients over
the years that were in hardship
situations and had massive tax bills and
we worked with tax attorneys that we
paid good money to not some goober on
cable television okay and you can get an
OIC through
but I'm telling you out of a hundred
that I work on or I have worked on over
the years I've gotten three or four
through it just doesn't happen okay you
don't want to be on that status well you
got the things you that you know it's
like well I it's inconvenient
inconvenient they don't care if it's
inconvenient you have a car sell the car
and pay me you have a house sell your
house and pay me they don't care if
you're homeless you don't care your
grandmother's Diamond brooch they don't
care sell it they want to know
everything and not revealing assets to
to them in this process is also criminal
fraud yeah so this is just is you're
just playing with tiger here you don't
want to deal with these people what you
want to do is get your taxes filed get
on a payment plan roll up your dadgum
sleeves and clean up your mess and quit
looking for easy fixes for major stupid
stuff usually major stupid stuff comes
with major problems to fix it yeah
there's no quick and easy you don't get
out of that quick it took you 20 years
to make the mess it didn't going you're
not going to get out in 20 minutes and
for the self-employed people that are
listening pay your dad gum taxes just
file your quarterly please just do it
and and and if you don't want to do it
yourself invest a little bit of money
and just hire a bookkeeper to stay on
top of this and make sure that that is
going through properly for you I'd
rather pay them a little bit of money
every year than deal with a tax burden
and deal with getting myself in hot
water with the IRS I'm just I'm $ 1099
and I forgot I had to pay taxes you
forgot you know I mean this is what they
I made 100,000 bucks I paid no taxes for
2 years that means you made 200,000
bucks that means you have a tax bill of
50 Grand laying around mhm or more and
so you know that's a lot you do not want
to have this crap sneak up on you it
it's not really sneaking up on you
you're just pretty much uh we just
discovered denial is not just a river in
Egypt you totally stuck your head in the
sand how's that okay so let's make it
clear Dave because we say all the time
don't don't use a professional for this
don't use a guy for this but use a guy
for this so make it clear when do not
use cable TV people to fix anything in
your money we don't use we don't do
consolidation the commercial runs
between Snuggies and walk-in bathtubs
it's not a credible operation okay hello
not snug think about it you know if your
if your financial advice comes between
walk-in bathtubs and Snuggies you got
bad financial advice I'm just telling
you okay that this is what you got think
about what's going on around you okay
this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
[Applause]
Jade was all Ramy personality is my
co-host today thank you for joining us
America Merry Christmas to you I'm Dave
Ramsey the phone number here Isle
88255 225 Williams in Charleston West
Virginia hey William how are you I'm
doing pretty good today can you hear me
sir yes sir how can we help all righty
Dave I'm William I'm 25 years old I make
90k a year as a truck driver I'm
currently on baby step 2 with I would
say less than $10,000 of debt a vast
majority of that being medical no credit
card debt um my card my cars are paid
off and my wife she's 25 working
part-time and she's able to go to
college for free through my uh
employment cool and our ultimate goal is
we are wanting to in two years be able
to
Homestead and start our
family and what I've came across and
I've heard is to consider looking at
getting a Homestead Property under a
business or LLC loan because it it's a
lower interest on the loan than most
mortgages right now and it could allow
that property to be more of a tax
advantage with being able to ride off
different things and different equipment
for the Homestead I was wondering what
your opinion was with
this
um well to start with i i i it sounds
like you're reading um people that are
proponents of homesteading and reading
lots of Articles and uh hanging out with
folks that do a lot of
homesteading uh and so it made you
susceptible to reading this stuff um
because that's not Main
information uh and it's also not
accurate okay so having an LLC and
getting a business loan is a higher
interest rate than a
mortgage than a person than a personal
mortgage rate So when you say Homestead
you're talking about buying a piece of
ground with a house on it that you're
going to live in and raise animals and
food and so forth correct yes sir okay
so what you need is you just need to go
get a mortgage and buy your house with
some property with it it's going to be
cheaper um and it is not your personal
residence uh interest uh I mean uh uh is
not a deductible business expense under
any circumstances now if you operate a
business on a piece of property that is
your residence for instance let's say
you bought I don't know make it up 30
acres and you put some cattle on there
okay yes sir you the cattle operation is
a business and you can deduct expenses
associated with raising the
cattle but not expenses
otherwise so it does not need to be a
LLC no you can you you you could buy
five cows okay and sell them at a profit
and deduct the vet bills and deduct the
feed and deduct if you had a piece of
equipment you were handling the cattle
with uh you could maybe depreciate that
piece of equipment okay to the extent
you use it on the cattle
but if you buy a truck and once a year
you touch a cow with it you can't write
the cow off except one day a year one
365th of the truck so it's a useless
bunch of crap to try to write your truck
off okay but if you've got a very
specific piece of information that is um
a livestock trailer and the only thing
it is used for ever is to transport
cattle in or out of your operation then
that that trailer could be either
expensed or depreciated depending on uh
the particular portion of the tax code
but you could do all of that as a sole
proprietorship you don't need an LLC you
can do it's called a Schedule C on your
taxes Schedule C is a small business and
a small business you write on there what
your income from the business was what
the expenses from the business were and
what the profit the net the income minus
the expenses is the profit and the
profit is taxable so you have deducted
you've had a deduction for the expenses
on the schedule C does that make sense
yes
sir you do not need an LLC to do
that okay this is the first time I'm
hearing of a Schedule C Business yeah
it's called a sole proprietorship you
would open a separate checking account
at your bank um cattle by William or
William Smith or whatever your last name
is DBA doing business as cattle by
William it has your social security
number on it you don't even need a tax
ID number for it okay and then run all
of your business income from the cattle
into that account all your business
expenses out of that account and
everything that's written down about
that account ends up going on the
schedule C and thereby you have deducted
your expenses from the income that the
cattle created but it's not a faux tax
deduction that you get on your lawnmower
because you're homesteading you don't
get
that okay does that make sense yes sir
see homesteading amounts to I'm going to
grow some of my own food and I'm going
to grow some food and sell it to other
people
right yes sir okay the the food you grow
for your own use no tax
deduction the only savings you get is
you get really good food A and B you get
uh cheaper food
agreed yes sir I've been looking at
homest setting with uh my wife as we're
getting more and more into the Bible and
I'm reading a lot more about how
everybody back then W was having farms
and getting food and I think one
financially it makes uh makes sense and
two it is the best quality that I feel
like I can get to give my future
children hey being a kid being raised on
a farm is about as good as anything can
be they know how to work they know how
to get dirt under their fingernails they
know where babies come from I mean
everything being on a farm is a good
thing right and it it's just uh when all
of America has spent some time on a farm
uh three generations ago this was a
better place and so I I completely agree
with you uh from a common sense
perspective I mean we can bring the
Bible into it if you want but uh I just
think it's great place to raise kids I
got no issue with it at all uh I mean my
kids are suburbanite kids but and they
survived because I made them do work but
uh but I mean what you're talking about
it's a fine standard of living a fine
way of doing things but there are no
magic tax pills that go along with it or
better interest rates that go along with
it you're just buying a small farm to
operate for your family I mean it's the
same principle that rolls into anything
else I mean if you even if you operate
you know a business from your home or
you work from your home there's a
certain amount but it's not everything
like it's only what is directly related
to that business well and here's the
problem like for instance can you ride
off a home office at home sure yeah you
buy a $300,000 house and it's 3,000 ft
and you have a 3 100 squ ft bedroom M
okay well that's 10% of your house 10%
of the 300,000 oh wait we got to take
out the lot because you can't depreciate
the lot so the lot is 100,000 of the
300,000 so now it's only 200,000 now
it's only 20 so and then you divide all
of that by 27 years and oh by the way
when you get ready to sell the house you
have recapture all of that depreciation
you took is added back as a taxable
event when otherwise if you had sold
your personal residence 100% of your
growth on the income or growth on the
value would been taxfree so screwing
around riding off your home one of your
bedrooms as a home office ends up
actually being a stupid idea that's a
good point Dave thinking long term yeah
but I mean because when it comes back to
bite you when you sell it you got 100%
recapture on that depreciation that you
took so it
just you know and people go I wrote All
I'm going to write off you can't write
off that you can only write off what
actually is attributable to the actual
function of the business and home office
or
homesteading you know just because you
saw it on Tik Tok it does it does not
change any you know it's not real we
actually have a great article on rs.com
about that very thing we do yeah we do I
I I by lined it so oh written by Jade
about home office check it out yeah
about knowing what to write off and
knowing what not to do and just all that
good stuff so if you have a chance check
it out um now here's the thing
homesteading is a great idea running a
business and starting it up out of your
house great idea doing either one of
them for the tax benefits dumb idea
there we go yeah I'm with you on that is
the Ramsey
[Music]
[Applause]
Show
[Music]
[Applause]
a
[Music]
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thank you for being with
us America Merry Christmas Parker is in
Portland Oregon hey Parker how are you
I'm good how are you better than I
deserve what's
up uh so I just bought my first house
six months ago and I just wanted to get
your opinion as to whether um or not I
should turn it into a rental to start
paying it off faster
no no no how old are you
21 what's the house
worth uh 245 what do you do for a living
I'm a tax accountant okay what are you
making 63,000 good so you can pay the
bill right yeah do you have any other
debt no
good for you okay so I first thing I'd
do is just sit sit down do a budget and
pay your house payment enjoy the house
sounds like it's a very nice
property how many how many
bedrooms it's not as big as you sound
it's just a two-bedroom two B and unit
condo okay all right um well I mean at
21 years old it's a pretty impressive
purchase okay if uh if if you want to
put in a roommate to try to help you
with the cash flow that that's not a bad
idea or an unusual
idea um but no I you do not need to be a
landlord in order to pay your house off
faster that that's going to work
backward M landlord is
expensive people tear up stuff I was
going to say moving back into a house
that you've turned into a rental for the
last 5 years it's not the same house
anymore it's or the same apartment in
your case anymore it's going to feel
totally
different okay are you not liking the
property are you not liking the
bill No I um I can afford the bill and
um I love it but I was just trying to
think of I was planning on moving in
with my boyfriend in um in June and then
having turning it into a rental and then
making extra principal payments on
it how long have you been dating the
boyfriend uh
year I wouldn't do that
um I definitely wouldn't do that I like
Dave's idea of getting a roommate I feel
like that's the quickest way to get
extra income in make those extra
payments that you want to
pay so that you can pay down this
mortgage quickly what's your goal like
what's your when you say I want to pay
this down quickly what's what's the
timeline in your
mind uh timeline is 10 years
okay I like that you're 21 you're going
to get there with no boyfriend and with
no
renters and um if your boyfriend turns
into your husband we can have a
different discussion M but um if I were
you now again you called us to ask what
we would do and that's what we are are
we're Duty bound to tell you based on
the fact that um I am old and have
experience I have to tell you these
things so um and it's just like a rule
and all I mean let's talk about why
though because when when you suggested
the boyfriend thing what came to my mind
is I'm thinking if you go live with the
boyfriend if something happens you guys
break up you broke up tomorrow night
you've got a renter in there who's under
a year lease or however long the lease
is now you're kind of homeless because
you've got a renter and you and your
boyfriend broke up that's what my brain
immediately goes to what's your mind go
to get married if it's time to get
married um I was your age when I got
married and we've been married 43 years
years and you know we've had lots of
renters and all that kind of stuff so um
you know uh actually Sharon I we 22 but
yeah yeah same here so
um that that's the thing so 42 years
coming up I guess it is but um anyway
yeah that I would just tell you if if
this guy is worth doing all this for
he's worth marrying and if you're worth
um all this then you're worth marrying
so or not uh but don't don't make
financial and economic decisions that
are interwoven with people you're not
married to it gets you in all kinds of
pinches and one of them is what was just
outlined by Jade right there so you can
do what you want to do I think you're I
think you're fairly um levelheaded and
ahead ofe of the game for a 21y old you
purchased a property youve tax
accountant you're making $65,000 a year
you're living in Portland Oregon on your
own you're making it life is good I
think you're I think you got a lot on
the ball you sound like you're really
sharp don't blow that by getting by
trying to speed something up
artificially whether it's the
relationship or whether it's the uh the
pay down of the house yeah just be the
tortoise don't be the hair Be steady
boom bo bo bo b b b Bo as a tax
accountant if you're doing accounting
for individuals you are going to
discover people that tried to get rich
quick and how quickly they went
broke and I'm trying to keep you you
from that side of the equation because
you seem to be very wise beyond your
years and um I want to keep you back on
the side of the equation that somehow
your parents got you on to start with
and I want to keep you there if I if you
know so if I sound like an old fogy then
chalk it up to the fact that I'm an old
fogy so there you go open phones at 8825
5225 and Jay truthfully I mean the truth
is this okay
um if you call into this show
our duty bound thing is to love you
that's right enough to tell you the
truth and um sometimes that's funny and
sarcastic and sometimes we're a little
mean uh and sometimes we tell you often
times we tell you something you didn't
want to hear it's not unusual either
that's right but
um you know our goal is not to we're not
taking a poll for popularity no we just
want actually help you that 5 years from
now you go you you know I wish I had
done what they said or I'm really glad I
did what they said uh because they know
stuff I didn't know and they've been
down roads I haven't been down and
they've helped people uh in more
complicated situations than I'm in and
so it's what we do that's right that's
what we do we spend our whole lives
doing this stuff and we're heavily
invested in it uh intellectually
emotionally spiritually prayerfully um
financially everything we're invested in
this so uh and so never confused that
we're doing anything here except out of
an act of love we love doing this we
love helping people and we love you guys
we want you to win and uh if that freaks
you out hey that's okay we love
that Emma in Milwaukee Emma what's up in
your
world hey Dave hey Jade how are you guys
doing today better than we deserve how
can we help awesome super excited to
talk to you guys today my question for
you is I recently got a promotion and it
overd doubled my income
wow what are you
making uh about 15 right now wow how old
are you 27
you're love it I don't want to tell you
what I was making when I was 27 wasn't
that much how can we help Yeah so
basically this has brought me to step
baby step po a lot quicker than I was
anticipating I am a master at baby step
1 through3 however um so I have my f six
month emergency fund saved away I also
have a little extra on top of that
totaling in 23 grand um I'm single I
currently rent I have no kids no other
major payments been living loow
maintenance for quite a while now um
what I'm wondering about is how to go um
about investing properly I can give you
some of my company's 401K situations and
then also on top of that is it a wise
decision to purchase land for my family
farm right now through land
contract well let's start my you're
doing everything right
go ahead I was going to say well let's
start with the investing side of it yeah
how about that so my my company will
match my 401k contributions at the rate
of 25 cents onto the dollar up to 8%
okay they also offer a rth that they
will match 8% let's do that do that okay
and you're going to put up to baby step
four you know the stuff Emma 15% of your
income and you're going to put it in
four types of growth stock Mutual Funds
growth growth and income aggressive
growth and international on the other
thing never do a land
contract because you do not have title
to the property and if you paid the
property down in half and have half
equity and the person who actually owns
the property gets in a car wreck gets
sued they have a lean against a property
that they own you don't own it but you
have a contract they can't deliver on so
you never do a land contract if they
want to deed it to you and give you a
mortgage you can talk about that but no
we're not doing any land contracts ever
very weak position for the buyer very
dangerous position for the buyer never
do a contract for deed or a land
contract which are the same thing that
puts us hour the Ramsey Show in the
[Music]
books
live from the headquarters of ramsy
salute tions it's the ramsy show where
we help people build wealth do work that
they love and create actual amazing
relationships I'm Dave Ramsey your host
thank you for joining us America jadea
Ramsey personality and author of the new
book the new quick read money's not a
math problem she's my co-host today
thanks for hanging out with us the phone
number is
88255 225 Mary Christmas kendre is with
us to start this hour in Houston Hi
kendre how are you I'm doing all right
how are you doing Dave better than we
deserve what's up
Sir hey so I was calling just to get
some advice so I am about $61,000 in
debt uh I make about 55 to 62,000 a year
just depending on you know what kind of
jobs we get I am uh I drive a concrete
mixer okay so you know our business is
generally driven by you know what kind
of contracts we get the weather you know
anything can affect anything and
everything can affect uh the paycheck
so I have about $119,000 in student loan
debt uh about $4,000 in credit cards and
the rest is a
$35,000 car loan which I pay about $762
a month for whoa you're feeling that
yeah yeah um so I think we found the
problem uh yeah are you upside down on
it so yeah definitely I owe $35,000 in
the car is worth $25,000 2021 Jeep Grand
Cherokee um I got it with no money down
as they would say I got put into a
situation where I got scared and then I
got stupid you
did okay so condition what kind of
condition is your credit
in uh my credit is now
in worst condition around the mid 500 it
was at a the who's the car loan
with um it's with CIG Financial it's
through a company uh through the
dealership AutoNation in uh
Houston
okay all right
um well the net result is you've got to
sell the car and we have to figure out
how okay I imagine yeah yeah because the
car is killing you I mean it's safe to
say that if you didn't have this car you
probably wouldn't have even called
us yeah definitely and I'm assuming you
don't have any money laying around no
savings nothing so I have I have half of
my baby step one uh the other half will
be going in at the end of this week and
after that no nothing okay so you got
500 bucks are you
married are you
married do we lose no sir I'm not
married okay
uh all right um and so you're you're
driving the concrete truck what 40 hours
a
week uh no I generally work anywhere
from 55 to 70 hours a week okay and
that's making the
65,000 yes do you are you're renting a
house or apartment uh we're renting in
an apartment what's the
rent uh
$100
okay all right so it may take a little
bit but here here's the the the formula
is we got to come up with 10 grand fast
mhm and that means beans and rice rice
and beans all the OT you can pick up or
side hustles you can pick up if you're
not picking up OT all right and you know
I want you to sign up for everything
they'll let you drive anything you can
do and beans and rice rice and beans no
restaurants no vacations no nothing till
we get 10 grand to cover the hole that
you're in and then you sell the car and
cover the 10 grand get you a $1,000 car
okay do you have anything else you can
sell anything associated with the
business that you don't need need uh no
uh other than this car honestly I've
been a minimalist for a very long time
uh I don't really until you met the
Grand Cherokee yeah yeah exactly that
that was the first and worst big thing
I've ever uh gotten in my life yeah and
I'm sorry you're stuck in this but
really you got to have the 10 grand the
other option and I don't think it will
work but I'll put it out here just
because it is a slight possibility you
might slide over there to auton nation
and say guys um I'm about to get
repossessed here cuz I'm having real
problems with this
car and uh I need you guys to let me
sign a note and pay payments on the 10
grand and uh take and let me sell the
car for 25 now who said the car is worth
25 where'd you get that information uh
so I uh went on Kelly Blue Book got the
quot private private
sale yes not trade in no trade in okay
all right so uh they might say we'll
give
you X number of dollars for the car and
let you sign a note for the difference
and if you pay $700 a month on $10,000
you can get it paid off pretty
quick right and I let me tell you I I
give you less than a 10% chance of that
working I was going to say what's the
likelihood of that but I would haul my
butt down there and sit in front of them
and and try it
right in person not on the phone and not
by email drive up with the car sit down
talk to the financial manager in person
and say I'm screwed here and don't blame
them you're you're not you're not a
victim you signed up for this right but
don't go in there and go you guys did me
wrong that's not the point we know they
did you wrong but that's not the point
so if he tries it and it doesn't work
then you got to come up with 10 grand is
there a situation where you would say
listen if I can get a credit card for
that 10 grand yeah yeah I'd take a
credit card for the 10 grand cuz I would
rather you owe 10 grand on a credit card
than 35 on a Grand Cherokee that's what
I'm
saying um I don't know how I would go
about getting the same Grand on credit
card I don't either not with a 550 I
don't but um you know I mean it could be
that your credit union will loan it to
you but I doubt
it right that's why I was asking about
your credit but if you got a credit
union that you got a long-standing
history with and the guy knows you in
there you might go in there and get 10
grand to cover the whole MH or 11 Grand
which is one to buy a car with you get
you a little a little garage sale car to
get back and forth to work
right you get rid of that 30 get the 30
get rid of 25 of the 35 you can deal
with the other 10 pretty quick MH okay
so if I if I were to pause the baby
steps until I can come up with like a
$2,000 for a little cash car and then
sell the $25,000 car yep you got to
cover the 10 grand difference but the
difference is that's that's where the
problem is is that 10 grand you can't
sell your car until you can get the
title for it and you have to pay them 35
to get the title right right right right
right okay that's why I keep trying to
come up with a 10 grand somewhere
M listen even if you can get and don't
go down there and let them screw you and
put you into another deal oh no
definitely not no more deals with these
people yeah I'm not trying to get any
more notes any more any more debt I'm
not we're going to help you out by
selling you a $20,000 car no you don't
need a $20,000 car you need out of the
$35,000 car
completely right no debt that's what we
need and then if you don't have any
payments when we clear this mess up I
mean you can then you can deal with the
other two things pretty quick you can
knock out $4,000 in credit card $199,000
student loan cuz you ain't going
stinking $750 payment anymore MH right
right so that this is that's why we're
spent the entire time talking to you
about getting out of this car well
that's the lesson the problem is in the
car almost every time uh man we used to
call this the sell the car show yeah
yeah Dave my my dog is ill sell the car
Dave my marriage is struggling sell the
car it was the answer to everything sell
the car sell the car this is the ramsy
[Music]
show
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my co-
host today she's the author of the new
quick read money's not a math problem
check it out 57 Pages later you will be
smarter than you were when you started
check it out it's right there at ramsy
solutions.com by the way if you guys
didn't know our every dooll app where
you give every dollar a name the world's
best budgeting app it um helps you
manage your money the Ramsay way it
works wherever you are iOS Android
online you can do it anywhere you want
you can start every dollar for free and
immediately see where you stand with
your money you can get organized you can
work with your spouse if you're married
both of you have access to it so you
know what's going on with your money
there's no uh no two tracks here there's
one track we're running together and new
to every dollar we'll show you a
long-term Financial road map you track
your net worth your debt free date your
retirement date your baby steps dates
and more you're going to love love this
brand new thing those of you that are
really into this stuff you're going to
every dollar just took a whole new Step
boys and girls we're going to
proactively coach you to build wealth
and reach your goals nobody else does
that you can download the free app for
iOS or Android go to everydollar.com and
get started and if you pay just a little
bit you can have all the connectivity to
your bank and get access to a whole
bunch of other things as well be sure
you check all that out and by the way
some of you for some reason I guess
you've been living in a cave or
something you didn't know this
mint is closing up
shop January 1 they're done wow they're
done they're closing it so you got your
budget stuff over on mint you got to
have a place to go yeah cuz they're not
they don't have anything for you they're
done they're done they're got they're
run running Credit Karma that's all
they're doing and there's no budgeting
tool there and we're the best and the
biggest budgeting tool out there so your
natural movement is to move your stuff
over to every dollar and we can help you
do that yeah and uh it's completely free
if you want it to be if you want to
connect to your bank do the other stuff
we can show you how to do that but we're
not going to be selling you know mint's
whole thing was they were using it as a
lead magnet they gave away mint for free
because they tried to sell you rocket
mortgage they tried to sell you credit
cards they tried to sell you
consolidation loans uh all kinds of debt
products are being sold in there every
day and they made their money selling
debt products we don't sell debt
products
obviously uh we sell education and part
of that is educating you on we're Opera
operating this app with every dollar and
we're running all kinds of free webinars
with Jade and George and uh Rachel are
all doing free webinars pretty regularly
on how to operate every dollar when's
your next one my next one oh gosh right
after the first of the year it's right
after the first of the year but for the
mint folks I just posted matter of fact
if you go over to my social media on
Instagram at Jade warshaw I just posted
a deal where if you're leaving mint to
go to every dollar we're giving you two
months I think it's two months for free
wow yeah so check that out cuz the link
is there it's in my stories and you can
click it and get and get that deal yeah
so just check out Wade's Wade Jade's
Instagram Jade Jade warshaw yeah Jade's
Instagram and uh she she'll get you a
deal there and uh if you're moving over
if you're navigating uh migrating from
uh the every do or from the mint closeup
shop situation because you just got a
few days and you know you're I don't
know when they're going to shut down the
access to your information but you want
to get your information out of there
before they shut the whole puppy down
well yeah certainly January 1 is their
shutdown date that's what they're saying
so you want to Bill be red D yeah John's
with us John is in Johnson City
Tennessee hey John Merry Christmas Merry
Christmas Dave how are you better than I
deserve what's up
man well me and my wife are looking to
buy a home sometime this year good we're
about
$34,000 in day at
bad yeah that's what I'm trying to get
situated I'm I want to get this at least
the biggest part of it knocked out
between now and sometime this year so we
can get situated to buy a house yeah you
need to get it all knocked out what do
you
make I make about 55,000 a year she
makes uh oh good what she makes uh
probably 25 or 30 so 85,000 and you have
34,000 on
what got 135 on a car um she's got a
student loan that we're paying on
together how much is that we had a her
student loan's a little less than 7,000
now okay what's the other
14 she had or we have got a loan
together where we we bought something
stupid we had to get out from under it
I'm not going to lie to you that's what
it was $300 I bought a motorcycle
oh I got stupid and then I got out of it
she got sick she started having some
health problems I saw the rting on the
wall so I got rid of the
motorcycle it cost you $8,000 to get out
of it it cost me six to get out of it or
no what's you got 14 more what's the
other eight I've Got U $1,600 on a
credit card and we have got a $7,000 in
a mower a lawn mower so we're selling
that yeah
okay so you're selling $7,000 lwn more
you're taking uh we're selling
everything else we can get our hand sell
some much stuff the kids think they're
next okay I want you to get a house all
this other crap goes down in value the
house goes up in
value right if you're going to keep that
car you guys need to work like 10 extra
jobs be going nuts from now until summer
and let's be debt free by summer but
you're going to have to sell you need to
sell the mower you may need to sell the
car but but if you're going to keep it
you guys are going to be working like
crazy people for a short period of time
here yeah and no eating out and no
vacations okay the bad thing about the
car is I'm not ever going to get out
what I owe in it never going to get it
what do you owe you owe 13 what's it
worth it's it's worth uh last time we
looked it was worth about 9,000 okay
yeah right so you got to pay it off it
it's easier cuz it's not it's not 35,000
it's 13 okay so you know yeah it's it's
not the problem it it's just part of the
problem and after we sell the lawn mower
it's the biggest part of the
problem right so the thing is this John
if you and your wife sit down okay let
me back up two steps I got just a second
I want make sure I lay this out right
one of the great speakers and teachers
of all time on self-improvement said
Earl Nightingale used to say that the
problem with people's not hitting their
goal in your case your goal is to buy a
house is not what you're willing to do
to get there that's not the problem it's
what are you willing to give up to get
there those are the things that block us
if you want to lose weight it's not what
you're willing to do to lose weight it's
what are you willing to give up that
you're blocker you see what I'm saying
and so what you guys have got to do now
is you've identified the goal is very
clear and it's a great goal and we're
endorsing the goal right Jade that's
right I want you house yeah we want you
to have a house it makes good Financial
sense good relational sense everything
and a bunch of this other crap does not
$7,000 lawn mower does not okay unless
you paid cash for it and you make a lot
more than you make so uh your wife is
working more than she's ever worked in
her life in the next 6 months you are
working more your family is doing
nothing we're not going out to eat and
we're going to have a bunch of sales and
we're going to sell a bunch of crap left
and right uh I mean eBay Facebook
Marketplace everything's going to be
activated at your place so that we can
hit the goal do you guys have
kids got two yeah because this is it's
just a good investment for your family
man and so I I I I would prescribe in
order to have a great life in the future
that you prescribe yourself six months
of Hell
mhm because if you move into this house
with no payments John the house will be
a
blessing right well see and I've I've
got uh I've got 12,000 extra dollars
coming in a year because I'm I'm
pastoring a church I'm a pastor so I've
got that on top of what I'm making so
okay then that go that goes into the
budget that goes into the budget and
every T every time I get a church check
I throw it on I throw it at a bill good
I want you to do more than that I want
you to add up all the checks and cut all
the expenses and put everything towards
these bills toward and work smallest
debt to largest debt and get rid of all
of them cut up the credit cards knock
the credit card out then then let's get
the car and let's get the student loan
knocked out and let's get the lawnmower
sold and so I mean you got you you got
$21,000 I mean 20 what is it $26,000 you
got to come up with and that's $2,000 a
month for a year that's uh $3,000 a
month you do it in six or eight months
and you're starting to talk about buying
a house by
fall but I want this to be a blessing to
you not a curse and if you buy this
thing with a bunch of Deb hanging around
your neck it's going to be a curse and I
don't want you to do
[Music]
that
Jade washaw Ramsey personality is my
co-host today if you're out running
around during the holidays we do this
radio show podcast YouTube thing every
day from 1 to four central
time uh we will be off between Christmas
and New Years you'll get best ofs on
those days but we're on the glass in the
lobby of ramsy Solutions so you can come
into the lobby and we have free homemade
chocolate chip cookies we like to
celebrate our listeners and our viewers
we like to have you come in we'll sign
your books and take pictures with you we
like hanging out with you at the
commercial breaks we're here every day
Monday through Friday unless it's a
holiday of some kind and again we're
here not here between Christmas and New
Year but uh otherwise you can come out
and there's usually 50 to 200 folks
hanging out it's completely free
experience we take care of you we we
want to say thank you for hanging out
with us and in in that Lobby we put a
little stage it's called the debt free
stage standing on the debt free stage is
Jason and Cassandra which can only mean
one thing well most likely means one
thing that's your debt free how much hey
guys where do y'all live we're from
Houston Texas ah welcome to Nashville
and how much debt have you paid
$124,000 excellent how long did that
take 48 months all right and your range
of income during that time well we
started at 100 7,000 together and we
ended at
158,000 excellent what do youall do for
a living I am a math and stats Professor
excellent I work in software development
okay very cool what kind of debt was the
124 there were two home loans um two
school loans for graduate school and two
adoption loans wow so this pays off the
house no not the house everything but
the house did I say house the first
house was from when we lived in East
Texas that's what you're talking about
the Home Loans two home loans I'm sorry
I'm very nervous okay two car loans two
car car loans okay we're just going to
let him translate that's okay no you're
fine it's good very good it's
nerve-wracking to be on the microphone I
understand not for me anymore after 30
years but the first time you do it it
scares the crap out of you you're doing
good very good all right 124,000 paid
off in 48 months tell us what started
this whole story this journey this
connection to Ramsay we we did FPU as a
couple in 2015 we were having trouble in
our marriage just I was doing I was I'm
the number person right I'm the math
professor but um I was doing it by
myself and so in 2015 we almost didn't
make it and so we were like we got to do
this and so we paid all of off all of
our Consumer Debt in
2018 um this whole time cash flowing
fertility treatments trying to get
pregnant for about 13 years wow um in uh
2017 we did get pregnant and uh got
evacuated from Harvey and came back and
not so pregnant oh man and so 20 18 may
we decided to adopt and we announced it
we started to GoFundMe and we started
cash flowing and they said probably
going to be 18 months y'all want two
kids under two you want biological
siblings good luck with that everybody
everybody told us that it was going to
be a year and a half wait to even start
so we filled out our paperwork and we
did our little home visit and then like
two weeks later they were like hey guess
what we got a match for you
so we believe that God had a mission for
us oh mercy yes yeah those these are our
little girls
without a doubt they are yeah they're
amazing the best thing that ever
happened to us amazing yeah so what a
story we stopped paying well now we uh
so in um 2019 our youngest was born in
October um 2018 and we have an open
adoption to this day she's still in and
out of our house um anyway so in January
of 2019 she placed the oldest with us
there was a delay and so in 2018 I was
on maternity leave 2019 I go back to
college and um now that we have both
girls which is what we always wanted um
we now have a basically $2 2,000 plus
dollar a month um take care bill as you
might imagine and um there was room and
then there was not room and even with
grants and GoFundMe and all of that uh
2019 we had a lot of food insecurity
some that he may not even have known
about so um we were very frugal with our
budget um we did not have credit cards
it was car loans and adoption loans and
um school loans
medical medical there was medical debt
yeah anyway anyway so yeah we we wanted
to get out of that and we wanted to we
wanted to get so you were debt free and
then all of this happened and there's
another pile of debt there's yeah
definitely some I had some school debt
that we had been working on so you
weren't debt free when you started it we
were not debt free when we adopted the
girls and getting out of that was
important to us so that we could make a
firm foundation for our all all our
fam's future Consumer Debt free that may
have been what I said the credit cards
we had paid off all of our credit cards
but you still had the cars we correct we
were doing small free okay on I saying
on credit cards it's okay it's okay I'm
trying to get the story straight in my
head so okay you're good so you had some
you'd reduce some debt yes and then the
girls came along and you got some more
debt cuz everything got real tight it
happened a lot quicker than we expected
I got you and then you decided four
years ago what happened right uh Lily
turned one and both of their birthdays
passed by and there was there was no
room forg people gifted us um things to
pretend as though those were our gifts
from um food banks and things like that
um and it just wasn't working and I I
blame Ken Coleman calling me a chicken
by using the statistics online that said
basically that 25% of all people are in
jobs that weren't so great and they are
just too scared to do anything about it
wow and um I did apply for another job
and uh I started a new job in January
20120 and got an immediate 50% Bon or
50% raise oh my goodness oh there we go
and I have since um become the stem
department chair and doubled that from
where I was previously and so like we
didn't have big enough shovel and in
2020 we did not have daycare bills
because no dayc carees were open um and
so we I was a full-time working
stay-at-home mom changing diapers on web
calls with no camera but you know just
yeah but doing both of those things and
um making the best of what was a very
bad year for a lot of people financially
it it helped us push us in the right
direction yeah you were able to turn the
corner and your your bigger shovel as
you said so that enables you to get the
whole mess cleaned up so you kind of
knew what to do but it was just tight
and then you changed the shovel size and
then Co helped uh not Co but I mean
being at home from the quarantine helped
I guess A Better Way say some expenses
Co didn't help anything but yeah um but
anyway I mean fouchy didn't help
anything for sure but anyway $2,000 is a
big saving big that's huge yeah yeah
well done well done so proud of y'all
how's it feel to be free now oh it's
what a
journey I I and and we just closed that
door you know we just closed the door
being in debt so we still feel we still
feel like you know keep everything as
tight as as we can and and I'm okay with
that yeah yeah that's fine I'm I haven't
changed my grocery budget it's been it
was about 300 in 2019 it's now gotten up
to about 600 but I'm still very proud of
myself to have been able to stay under
that grocery budget yeah that's money is
not a math problem it's so true come on
now like from the math professor like I
was the solution and the problem all the
same time I knew the numbers is just
sticking to them so yeah that's right
that's right wow so what do you tell
someone who is in your situ talk to that
person who they're they're they're in
the fertility battle they've got debt
they don't see the the light on the
horizon right talk to that person right
now and you
know God is bigger than your problems
and just because you can't see the exit
doesn't mean it's not there for you you
can you can get through this and so
surrender I mean I would love to say
that it's this that and the other it's
Jesus Christ Alone come on now the point
when we get to Just Surrender and stop
trying to control it and I'm going to
make this work and I'm going to get
myself pregnant and all of that like no
get the best thing I ever did was just
let go just to let go and let him him
direct the way and him direct the story
and just him seeing us on the other
side I didn't do it he didn't do it I
mean we we did some stuff but I don't
think we could have alone ever got there
had we not got to the point where we
Just Surrender and say okay Lord you you
handle our story line yeah it is amazing
when you surrender and plant corn and go
I'm not in charge of sun and Rain wow
I'll plant the corn but I'm not in
charge of sun and Rain yeah it helps
helps a bunch there's there's a huge
release there proud of you guys way to
go Heroes what a testimony couple of
beautiful babies and uh these girls are
they're with you so it's Lily and give
me your other one's pronunciation Jala
she go Jala Jala l and jelix I love it
look how pretty they are I love it very
good well done you guys hey we've got
the baby steps millionaires book for you
The Total Money Makeover book and the
Financial Peace University membership
count it down guys Jason and Cassandra
224,000 paid off in 48 months making 107
to 158 let's hear a debt free scream all
right 3 2 1 we're dead
free love it what a great story wow
Merry Christmas America wow this is the
ramsy
[Applause]
[Music]
show
our scripture of the day Colossians 45
be wise in the way you act toward
Outsiders make the most of every
opportunity Charles Dickens in A
Christmas Carol it's the 180th
anniversary of the book publication
today no space of regret can make amends
for one's life's
opportunity
misused you don't hear that kind of uh
language syntax used when you're talking
about it was the best of times it was
the worst of times B humbug right but no
space of regret can make amends for
one's life's
opportunity
misused very powerful MH Brandon is in
Cincinnati Ohio hi Brandon how are you
I'm fine merry Christmas to you and J
it's a pleasure to talk to both of you
Merry Christmas to you how can we
help so uh Dave my wife and I we are uh
newly in baby step three we are
renters um I have a I just spoke to my
HR department because I have a a
corporate credit card so like my
company's name is on there and and and
my name I'm added as an authorized user
M so I I have it to pay for like my work
expenses when I travel submitting
receipts and expense reports and so I
was calling today to ask who's the card
with um it's it's with it's with my
company no I mean is it American Express
is it Chase is it visa MasterCard City
Bank City Bank City Bank Mastercard or
VISA um I believe it's either one of
those it's one of those right you
correct and it's the comp in the
company's name and you're an authorized
user correct that's right I'm with you
now I'm catching up okay good okay so
yeah so I um I spoke to them and uh to
one of the H leads and you know I was
asking about like can I do a debit like
can I do like a business debit card or
could you advance you don't need to
you're not liable on this
card oh I'm not okay no you're fine on
this card you don't want a corporate AMX
cuz the corporate American Express
requires you to sign for liability but a
corporate Visa or Mastercard with a a
standard Bank like a Chase or a city is
not going you're not liable that you're
just your name is on the card let me
give you an example I did not know that
yeah the um the like I've got Visa debit
cards here at the company okay right uh
they're our company's account our
company's card but uh I I don't know do
you have one of them I do you have a a
company card okay she's an authorized
user on it but she has no liability if
there's misbehavior with that account
the company is the only thing that's
liable not Jade MH now if she misbehave
with it that'd be different but I'm
saying if uh if some kind of if some
kind of thing happened it doesn't come
back on her she authorized user just
means you're allowed to sign for the
company well what's the difference with
the AMX AMX is a bunch of shyers and I
can't stand them and they have their
company their MX corporate cards require
the employee to also be liable what and
I've had I've had several clients over
the years come in that their company
went bankrupt and left them holding a 15
or a $20,000 MX Bill wow yeah but that's
not going to happen with Brandon Brandon
you're safe you're fine don't worry
about what you got you're Dave can I ask
you a question on behalf of other
listeners okay um let's say if they had
a like a American Express business card
a credit card if they were in my shoes
and baby sets three like just starting
out how I would I would turn it in I
would get off of it I would cancel it I
would not participate with American
Express in any way it's dangerous should
they prioritize like hurrying up and
finishing d73 and then to do with it I'm
just I would go into the company and go
get my name off of this I'm not going to
sign for anything using this period
gotcha
here's what happened okay I had a guy
went to uh his company sent him to uh
Europe and he was picking up some Tech
equipment he came back and the Tech
equipment was shipped in it was $25,000
worth of stuff and he put it on the
company AMX card when he got back home
went to the office the office had a
padlock on it they were in bankruptcy
and shut down AMX chased him down for
the 25k and it was a company
card right now that's not true with your
City Bank visa
corporate card or it's not true with a
debit card that Jade is carrying you're
just allowed to sign for them as all
you're not you have not signed an
agreement to sign for
liability wow a lot of people just got a
wake up call on that yeah really
dangerous yeah but if for those that are
in that situation should they like how
should they cash flow it like where in
like if they were in baby have three
should they finish that first if they
had to get reimbursement like pay the
expenses up front and then C and then
get reimbursed yeah they're going to
have to I guess they're going have to
cover their own
expenses I'd set up a separate debit
account just for travel and that kind of
stuff if MX is the only way your company
will do it but I'm telling you man most
Mo most companies have moved away from
MX because of that most of them are
doing what you're doing if they're using
a credit card uh they're Furnishing a
corporate card or they're asking you
period they don't have anything and they
just ask you to use yours and then they
do a reimbursement monthly a lot of
companies still doing that mhm MH but we
furnish the equivalent of what your
company is Furnishing only ours is debit
yours is credit but like Jade has a
Ramsey solutions for travel because
Ramsey personalities do a lot of travel
I probably got a hundred of those things
out in the building here give or take I
signed some stuff today this morning for
one of our senior VPS was moving some
stuff around on it but um yeah but but
but uh anything she buys I mean she
she's not liable for the bill and you're
not liable for the bill in this case
either so you're fine I wouldn't I
wouldn't worry about it at all PJ is in
New York City hi PJ how are you hello Mr
Ramsey Miss Warsaw thank you guys for
having me on sure what's up so just I
guess I set the foundation I'm 23 I live
home little to no expenses um I have
term life insurance for 35 years I have
a Roth IRA however at the moment I have
little to no
income I do have a uh well I was I
joined uh uh I guess we can call it an
MLM for about a year year and a half
thinking it would uh work out for myself
and um and I realized that is not the
way to go okay so now you're looking for
a job uh well I actually have one lined
up I'm taking some of my uh Securities
licensing exams at the moment and uh I'm
lucky to have a connection in the
industry where Once I pass those exams I
have a job lined up so that that'll be
by be uh be a little bit after the start
of a New Year good um so I'm I'm blessed
to be in the position that I'm in okay
so now we're in February and you're
making money all right now watch your
question correct so um the thing is I
really have little to no uh education or
knowledge on credit um of course I don't
want to live at home forever um I've
done my research online uh however I'm
just slightly confused so I figured why
not ask you guys I just really don't
even know where to start I don't have a
credit card I pretty much just have a
debit card yeah yeah so why do you need
credit uh that's the thing I'm not too
sure if I do or don't need
it credit's for people who want to who
credit is for people who plan on taking
out debt and borrowing money for their
lifestyle that's that's the only that's
the only reason it exists so if you have
said I don't want to borrow money and I
don't want debt I'm going to pay cash
for my life then you don't need credit
score do you uh I don't believe so just
I guess with be uh I guess the the noise
I've been hearing growing up and whatnot
is uh if you want to get a house one day
you need good credit score yeah the two
the two areas most people are going to
push back on that is a if you're going
to buy a car but we plan on buying our
cars in cash right is what it sounds
like you said which you can you save up
you buy cash cars right the next one is
the mortgage people push back and say
yeah you can't buy a mortgage without
credit and you actually can you can buy
a home you with a zero credit score so
if you never take out debt or maybe you
pay off your debt eventually your credit
score Will Roll to zero and if you never
take out debt it'll stay at zero or
indeterminable and a zero credit score
is just as good I would say better than
a good credit score or a high credit
score you can do just uh the same thing
that you need to do when it comes to
buying a home and so yeah you're just
doing what's called manual underwriting
and you get a mortgage company that
knows how to do that called like Church
Hill mortgage that we endorse as an
example so PJ I like what you've done
just keep it simple man M don't go in
debt so that you have the opportunity to
go in debt so that you have the
opportunity to go in debt so that you
have the opportunity to go in debt
that's called dumb and people do it
every day that puts us hour the Ramsey
Show in the books we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the Prince of Peace Christ
Jesus
[Music]
[Applause]
n